[Music]
every agent in ballarat has their own
unique ultimate ability which can work
really well
in certain situations but none of them
are as exciting to watch
as jets a good gentle can win an eco
round with
ease and completely turn the tide of an
entire match
watching a good jet player use their
knives can be something
truly special just before we get into
this i want to remind you guys to
subscribe to the channel
if you haven't done so already we're on
the road to two million subs
and you can help us get there all right
let's get into this now
with the top ten gentles
kicking off our list we have one of
europe's jet gods
cmed cena just stepping up this is
one of the best 3ks i've seen from a jet
that one and then this is just
oh in game one of their semi-finals
match against
fpx at vct masters cena put ascend on
his
back with a 3k to keep them in the game
he nailed an op shot before
falling back into hooker where he landed
two incredible right clicks with his
knives to all but seal the round up to
go for this though can he
want to get away he does again the
mystic falls they're gonna try and
charge him down here zip and
they're just on the other side oh my god
athena finds another one
that is insane right now it's absolutely
on fire no one can touch this guy
he has just dominated this they expected
him to fall away
but he stayed out there he got caught by
all of it he still manages
coming in at number nine it's tense
absolutely
running through his solo queue opponents
one enemy remaining okay who is this
now you probably noticed how tense used
tailwind to send himself onto site
before getting the entry kill on cipher
but what's really special about this
play is the way he used his updraft to
avoid the breach ult
and bag three quick kills before finding
the last player
cowering in spawn
one enemy remaining okay who is this guy
where are you
wait wait
flying into the number eight spot we
have some heroics from sentinels igl
shazam trying to split they're dashing
in though and shazam
lights up the kill feed that is the big
play they needed to get back in the
round
with his team trying to keep envy off of
match point
shazam came up clutch with a bladestorm
4k to keep his team
in the game with a little tailwind and
updraft action
this play just looks sick when they're
dashing in though and shazam
lights up the kill feed that is the big
play they needed to get back in the
round
and now we are even across the board the
health bar sure they hurt
but shazam continues to move forward
a 3v2 as envy try to close it out a 3v1
and sentinels will live to fight another
day off the back end of a 4k
from shazam the one and only wardell is
behind and number seven play now and you
can hear
how excited he was about this one
let's go wardell has been one of the
most exciting jet players since valorum
came out roughly a year ago
and this lightning fast 4k on ascent
should remind you why
moving on to number six we have a nasty
ace from g2's golden boy
mixwell any worries we had about them
unbind have been quickly answered
there's
here comes mixer for the eggs and there
it is i mean that's
beautiful plate with the jet and that's
why he is playing jet as well
in the group stage of the vitality
european open
mixwell showed that he isn't afraid of
anybody
a quick dash onto b site let him drop
three apex's players before
hunting down the remaining two all the
way on the other side of the map with
full
force with g2 here gonna find maxik on
site turns around and finds basics as
well
in glass this is oh
no mix well you can't do it to them it's
gonna find the third on to flash as well
and he's gonna keep searching i think he
wants this ace he's gonna push in
we'll find the four second series and
any worries we had about them unbind
have been quickly answered is
here comes mixer for the eighth and
there it is i mean that's
beautiful plate with the jet and that's
why he is playing jet as well
now this list just wouldn't be complete
without a korean
jet play of course which is why we have
xc from tnl esports at our halfway point
all right my god xc with three kills 1v1
does it and wow i am changing from
my name from tasteless to speechless
it's 1v4
but xc did not care he isolated
all four of his opponents and took them
out one by one before getting the defuse
korean jets are just something else oh
get him as he comes around the corner
echo does
eugene and texture are picking up echo
and bale respectively
spike is being planted camp off from
that distance right there
and again texture great play actually
comes into the corner this is so crazy
yeah this is insane by texture
but it does get offed
right my god maxie with three kills 1v1
does it and wow i am
changing from my name from tasteless to
speechless
flanking his way into the number four
spot now is the headshot machine
scream scream last man standing
bladestorm online
halfway there takes down one screen
[Music]
in overtime in the grand final of the
red bull home ground tournament
screen pulled off one of the best flanks
valorum has
ever seen all of his teammates had died
on site but
scream managed to take out all of g2 by
himself
to prevent the defuse liquid already
trying to play deep but keep your eyes
on the mini map look at that flank
coming through once again from scream
see if they can buy the time for him to
be as much of a nuisance as he was
before artist
he's gonna find one two three oh my word
scream last man standing bladestorm
online
halfway there takes down one screen
and they're like look you think you're a
good artist that's pretty
that's real nice but let me just stop
the defuse
in a 1v3 in ot of the grand finals
look at this goddamn player
coming in at the number three spot we
have shazam once again
keeping his team in the game they have
to take him out he gets two
looking for a third here's the charge
and he's gonna find moose as he lays
down the verdict get out of here
fighting off a match point and already a
man down in the round shazam was left on
an
island on split a site with only a judge
and
jetta but he came up huge taking out two
members
of lg with his knives before finishing
off a third with his shotgun
that gave his team enough time to rotate
and win the round to force overtime it
was very quiet on the side of lg
smokes and the rest ready you can see
the omen getting into position here's
your boy dre sets this
up and shazam ready in the back of the
site
they have to get in they have to take
him out he gets two looking for a third
here's the charge and he's gonna find
moose as he lays down the verdict get
out of here
sentinels will bring it to overtime in
map too
sentinels and shazam went on to win all
of
masters only dropping a single map what
a run
in our runner-up spot now we have the
one and only smig
a nice little smoke to give a bit of a
one-way on to corey the knives are still
out though as baby bay is looking for
the ace still has some spokes available
goes for the swing it's baby bay with
the ace
baby bay is simply one of the best jets
in
n a and here's a perfect example why
in the challenger 3 grand finals he
ripped through 100 thieves even killing
a sumo twice before
clutching the round so you don't really
have anybody playing towards belt
so faze recognizes that and for two
rounds in a row they push forward
that's a player you're gonna have to
watch out for as asuna
is punished by baby bay again in an
aggressive position
but let's not forget there's the sage
reds
there you go that's a nice little
advantage that's going to cause a peek
out coming in from the knives of baby
bay
who's found now three kills on the round
on the beef a nice little smoke to give
a bit of a one way on to corey the
knives are still
out though as baby bay is looking for
the ace still has some smokes available
goes for the swing it's baby bay with
the ace
and at the top spot we have the korean
jet himself
soul down
just about every korean jet montage
features plays from seoul down but in
this vct japan qualifier
he pulled off one of the most disgusting
aces we have
ever seen
all right guys there we go those were
some pretty insane gentles
but we want to know from you now what
sort of valorem content do you want to
see from us next
what valor and top 10 list do you really
want to see from us
let us know in the comments section
thanks for watching guys and i'll see
you all
in the next one
oh
[Music]